- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is get a little bit of practice
estimating dividing with decimals.
So for example, we wanna
figure out approximately,
that's what these kind of
squiggly equal sign means.
This means approximately equal.
So what does 80 divided by
1.94 approximately equal?
So we wanna estimate what this is.
So pause this video and see
if you can figure it out.
So before we even look at these choices,
how would we try to do this in our head?
Well, we could say 1.94, it's
hard to do that in our head
to divide it into 80 but
it's awfully close to two.
So we could say this is close to,
this is approximately
equal to 80 divided by two
'cause once again, 1.94
is awfully close to two
and then this is easy to figure out.
That is going to be equal to 40.
So our first expression, you could say
is approximately equal to 40.
Is it exactly equal to 40?
No but it's pretty close.
So I would select that choice.
Let's do another one.
So pause this video
and see if you can figure
out the approximation.
What is 209 divided by
three roughly equal to?
So once again, here we don't
have any clear decimals.
If we were to divide it out,
we would get a decimal
answer for our quotient
but what we could do is
well, is either one of these,
is for example 209,
is it close to a multiple of
three that we might recognize?
Well, you might immediately recognize,
well, if you think about
multiples of three,
you think in terms of,
well, three times six is
18, three times seven is 21.
Well, this is close to 210.
So this is approximately
equal to 210 divided by three.
Now, why is this interesting?
Well, 210 is just 21 times 10.
So if 21 divided by three is seven,
210 divided by three is
going to be equal to 70.
So once again, 209 is pretty close to 210.
Remember, we're just estimating
and so 209 divided by three
would approximately be equal to 70
which is that choice right over there.
Let's do one more example.
So once again, pause the video
and figure out what 6.86 divided by 1.12
is approximately equal to.
Alright, so here I would just try to round
to the nearest whole number
and see if that helps
my division in my head.
So 6.86 is approximately seven
if we round up to the nearest whole number
and if I say seven divided by,
and if we round down, 1.12,
seven divided by one,
this is much easier for
us to do in our head.
So that is going to be seven.
Now, once again, it's
very important to realize
these are estimations.
It's not going to be
exactly equal to seven
but it's definitely gonna
be much closer to seven
than 70, 700 or 7000.